I don't need motivation oh [ __ ] then let
me go that depends on you how you should
doesn't care that I'm stopping by does
she [ __ ] no I usually doesn't go out
much you're gonna kill me aren't you if
you're calm help us find the money and
do what I say Oh chef ed my word now he
looks like a lizard though not again are
the gun great even much code for
actually stayed in the hand no way
fish
oh [ __ ] okay okay we all know what's
gonna happen now Oh
oh good good luck is the spit
Jesus really uncalled for [ __ ] you right
back right now that's crazy did I go as
I see the chest other side but you
really ain't holding that long
I need God
okay okay i could do that sir this is
easy no it's good looking too good I got
some animals outside yes they still for
a sec hey I guess there's no mo that's
fun that was like dying I guess not
that's a bad shape we need to get to the
hospital
how at their ticket not Dan too good
emotionally oh [ __ ] okay this isn't good
yeah jump this curb and chill for a sec
all right hon shred that's easy
Oh
it's all close to the vehicle yeah to
get these days
oh [ __ ] I kept
how can a guy get get get a [ __ ]
Oh
Wow oh alright alright biggest rim seen
by meet it I'm Robin oh yeah no I fan
it'll do good
I'll lock up no I'm Harvey emotional
changes to you
what the hell
I like that takes a second to like hit
make fire it's all [ __ ] up
he has vehicles like indestructible
basically
PSS
what's this guy's plan
that's the guys [ __ ] tripping
scars on so Stokes is so [ __ ] up
and oh come fire this ain't gonna be too
good
no fire burn out this one there's fire
comes with a car [ __ ] [ __ ] this kind of
gone
this guy's more like so slow
ok
all right there's pretty easy mission
[ __ ] it what the [ __ ] this guy gone
doors are lean close anymore
it's with him the [ __ ] long take
driving like cart empty car speed well
like I [ __ ]
thanks for the write execute [ __ ] not
[ __ ] Pierce listen up Johnny got laid
out by one of the Roman that mean I
don't get too excited [ __ ] dad will
be back up in no time just shut up and
listen yeah percentage with Japanese
crime boss called the coogi this that's
coming into town soon and I want to know
when's good don't [ __ ] this up Pierce
I'm not nervous yep hey I got it you
know
that's got that that's all for now